[音楽]
tee
ran
none
tee
then
[音楽]
wh
俺はナイトレイさんが始めた
ここでは速い奴が一番得ないつまりここでは俺が一番偉い
今回俺に飛んでくる奴ならこいつら
どうやら4人がかりで俺を倒そうとして準備してきたようだ
なかなか速そうな奴らだが俺の席ではない
誰からでもかかってこい
なんなら俺から行ってもいいんだぞねっ
amaran
それから行こう
よしやってやれ
ん
1マイルは短いようで長いポイントはいくつかある
まずは最初のコーナーここのコーナーリングガンノズルつのレースを決めると言っても
過言ではない
そして見せ場である最高スピードケース田野ここで50万のトップスピードを
見せつけることの転居
コーナーを曲がったら同様のコース思い集あとはゴールまで全力で駆け抜ける
分
所詮そんなもんかうん
俺に任せろーんん
[音楽]
ああああああ
wh
[音楽]
俺の出番だな
ねぇ
[音楽]
me
car
実は俺が一番ええ
me
ええええええ
いいいいいい
car
ana
mar
どいつもこいつもこんなモンスター
花 c ならない
これがオート不思議だん
[音楽]
[拍手]
wh
none
いいいいいい
me
持っています
beware
goo
[拍手]
me
ええええええ
[音楽]
tee
ええええええ
bea
君はないとレーサー初めにさせるべく
大貴+アプリを食べようとして1マイルのタイムアタックに挑戦所
みんなアーカイブを教えてくれ
[音楽]